- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is dig a little bit deeper
into our understanding of multiplication.
And just as an example,
we're going to use four times seven.
And some of you might know
what four times seven is,
but even in this case,
I think you might get
something from this video
because we're gonna think
about how you can break down
a multiplication question
into simpler parts,
and that's going to be useful
well beyond four times seven.
It's going to be useful in your future
when you're tackling more
and more complicated things.
Now there's a couple of
ways that we can visualize
four times seven.
My favorite way is to
visualize it with angry cats,
so let's bring on the angry cats.
(imitates cats meowing)
Yep, they're still angry.
And we can see that
this is a representation
of four times seven.
We have four rows right over here.
Four rows,
and each of those rows have seven cats.
And so you can see that right over here,
each of those rows has seven cats.
Some people would call
this a four by seven grid
or four by seven array,
however you want to view it,
but if someone were to ask
you what's the total number
of cats, it would be four
rows times seven columns,
four times seven.
Now another way to
represent four times seven
is also with a tape diagram.
You might see something like this,
where here, we're visualizing
it as seven fours,
or you could view it as
four plus four plus four
plus four plus four plus four plus four.
Now that's all well and good
and you can add that up,
if you like,
but what I promised you is
that we would figure out ways
to break down things
that might simplify things in the future.
Well what if you didn't know
what four times seven is,
but you knew what four times five is
and you knew what four times two is?
Well what's interesting is
that seven is five plus two,
so what if we tried to first
figure out this many cats,
so four rows and five
columns right over there,
and then we tried to figure out
this many cats?
Four rows and two columns.
And you can see that it's the
exact same number of cats.
So one way to think about
it is four times seven
is the exact same thing as four times,
and I'm gonna use parentheses,
and that just means
to do that part first,
is equal to four times,
instead of seven,
I could write that as five plus two,
'cause that's what seven is,
so all this is saying is four time seven
is the same thing as
four times five plus two,
where you do the five plus two first,
'cause we have those
parentheses around it,
and five plus two is,
indeed, equal to seven,
and we can see that that is
equivalent to the total number
of cats that we have here,
which we could view as
what we just circled off
in this orangeish pink color
which would be four rows of five,
so that would be equal to four times five.
Four times five,
and then to that, we can add
this second group of cat heads
or angry cat heads,
and that is four rows of two.
So that's four times two,
and we could put parentheses if we want,
just to make it a little
bit more readable.
Now why did I do that?
Well, some folks might
find four times five
a little bit more straightforward.
I could skip count by five.
I can go five, 10, 15, 20.
Also four times two might be a
little bit more straightforward,
and so it could be easier to say hey,
this is just going to be four times five,
which is 20, plus four times
two, which is equal to eight,
and so that is just
going to be equal to 28.
And you could have thought
about it the same way down here
with what is sometimes
called a tape diagram.
We could say, all right,
if I have five fours,
that's this mount right over here.
That is the four times the five,
and then I could add
that to the two fours,
the four times the two right over here,
and that's another way to
get to four times seven.
So the big picture here is
even if you're not dealing
with four times seven,
if you're not dealing
with angry cats, and in most of our lives,
we actually try to avoid angry cats,
there might be a way to
break down the numbers
that you're multiplying into ones
that you might be more familiar with.
I'll give you one more example.
Let's say someone were to ask you, well,
what is six times nine?
Pause this video and see
if you can break this down
in some useful way.
Well, maybe you know what six times 10 is,
and you also know what six times one is,
so you could rerwrite nine
as 10 minus one.
Well then this would
mean that six times nine
is the same thing as
six times 10 minus one.
Based on exactly what we just did up here,
that says that this whole thing
is going to be the same
thing as six times 10.
Six times 10
minus six times one.
One way to think about it is,
I just distributed the six.
That's the distributive
property right over there,
and then six times 10 is equal to 60,
and then six times one is equal to six.
And it might be easier for me to say, hey,
16 minus six in my head,
that's equal to 54.
So I know what some of you are thinking.
Six times nine seems so clean,
and now I've involved all
of this other symbolism,
symbols, and I've written
down more numbers,
but at the end of the day,
I'm trying to give you skills
for breaking down problems
and including ways that you might want
to do it in your head.
If you're like, hey, I'm kind of foggy
on what six times nine is,
but six times 10, hey, I know that's 60,
and six times one, of course, that's six,
well what if I view this
as six times 10 minus one?
And then I could tackle it and get 54.
And once again,
you might know six times nine.
You might know four times seven,
but in the future,
it might be useful for
bigger and bigger numbers
to think about how
could I break this down?